- Alright, Samuel Leeds here,
and I am the best selling
author of this book
Come closer, Elliot,
Buy Low Rent High, and
if you haven't read this,
you are an idiot.
(woman laughs)
What is this video about?
In this video, I wanna talk to you about
some of the predictions I made
a year, two, three years ago.
Where the market is at right now,
and where it's going in
the future, so stay tuned.
(eerie music)
Tanya, what is your job?
- My job is to source
everything that you would buy.
- Absolutely, I had one in
Tanya, she used to be an
estate agent, she used to
bring me so many good houses,
HMO's, single lets, buy-to-let
properties, buying flips.
They were so good I asked her
to come work in the business
full time here in the glorious Elton Hall.
Two years ago we were
sourcing houses, right?
- Absolutely.
- We were sourcing houses,
HMO properties, for myself
to buy, and for our investors
to buy, and they were
properties that were around
about £85,000 up to £100,000
for four-bed HMO's, okay.
In Wolverhampton, Walsall,
Dudley, areas like that.
Today, in 2018, not only have
prices gone up considerably,
I'm looking at the screen right now,
I can't find a house within
20 miles of Wolverhampton,
that's less than £100,000.
Even if it's a three-bed
house, not a four-bed house.
Look, let me show you, come!
This is just insane,
so okay, so Rightmove.
Now this isn't like clever, clever stuff,
this isn't offline, just
online, you're on Rightmove,
and you type in, say, Wolverhampton.
Can you see the screen okay there?
Yeah, cool.
So price range, we're gonna
go minimum to £100,000,
three bedrooms, probably type houses.
Let's see what we've got.
26 results!
And out of those 26 results,
all of them are, like, auctions.
Okay, 95, oh, surprise surprise.
- (indistinct)
"Only showing to cash buyers."
Why?
Probably because there's what,
what's wrong with the house?
- Mine shaft, Japanese...
- Mine shaft!
Then there's this one, let's
have a look at this one, 95.
- I viewed it, bedroom
three doesn't measure up.
- I know, but forget it even if it's HMO.
There probably will be something
wrong with it, probably.
- Look at the damp on picture one.
- And look at the size bedrooms.
- But I mean, yeah yeah
look, oh my goodness, look!
- So here's my point, here's my point.
- There aren't houses
available for less than
a hundred grand, that are
just three-bed houses,
forget HMO's, forget four-beds.
Three-bedroom houses in Wolverhampton,
they just don't exist.
- So here's my point right now.
- If you are watchin' this video,
and you bought a house from Tanya,
that was a four-bed HMO in Wolverhampton,
a year or two ago, I think
you owe Tanya a drink!
- (laughs)
- I think you owe Tanya a drink!
- Absolutely, I'll accept what I ...
- Because not only you probably
got £1400 rent a month,
1,400 a month rent,
because it would have been
such a good HMO, but even if
you didn't get quite that much,
or even if you did, on top
of that, your house now
would probably be worth
130, 140, 150, 160?
- Absolutely, especially the
ones resourced in Birmingham.
My goodness!
- Oh, let's look at
Birmingham, come, come, come!
- Right, that was Wolverhampton.
Let's look at Birmingham.
- So Birmingham.
(keyboard typing)
- You can't even get into Dudley nowadays.
- Okay, Birmingham city
center, let's do within a mile.
Price range no minimum,
up to 100,000, three-bed.
And we're looking at
houses, so three-bed house.
Let's see what we got.
We got three results!
So, and out of those results
there'll be nonsense,
like look, this one is
an auction, so that will
go for a lot more than a hundred.
This one is offers over
and it's an auction.
And this one is also an auction.
So, come back to me.
There's only three houses
in the whole of Birmingham
that are, it's just nuts! And we...
- If anything that just proves your point,
that you've been drilling into
investors for years and years
and years, and it proves
that we are sourcing
really good deals.
- And by the way, guys, this is being
post the Brexit announcement.
So all those people that
were saying "Ooh, what about
Brexie, what about..."
Houses have just been going
up and up and up and up.
So what does this mean to you today?
I guess this means that
the 25-grand-a-room thing,
you know what I said in my book?
- Yeah.
25-grand-a-room, that is
completely not the case any more
if you're talkin' in the Midlands.
I'm sorry.
Right now, you're probably
talking more like 35 grand a room
in the Midlands.
It could still stack up
because another thing
that's shot up like crazy is rents.
- 31%!
- Rents have gone up 31%
in the last how long?
- Year.
- In that last year?
- Well, in Birmingham, Wolverhampton.
- Right, so the Midlands
have just gone poof!
Now you could invest in the
Midlands right now if you want.
You're not gonna manage to do it like
you used to two years ago.
You can invest in the Midlands or
you can invest a little bit further north
where this is gonna happen again.
'Cause the thing is
everywhere follows London.
So this happened in London five years ago.
Five years ago in London,
houses have doubled in London
in the last seven years, in some parts.
Now we're seeing it
happening, it's kinda happened
in parts of the Midlands,
it's gonna happen up north.
So if you're right now buying a house in
Grimsby, Middlesbrough, where else?
- Doncaster, Bradford...
- Yeah, those areas, and you're thinkin'
"Ooh, is it gonna rent out really fast?"
I think it will rent out.
I think you're okay, I think you're okay.
I've got houses in those areas myself.
But on top of that, watch
the capital appreciation
over the next few years.
(pounds desk) Boom!
And you'll owe us a drink.
Anyway.
- (laughs)
That's me done today,
so invest in property.
Ya get paid twice in property,
once in capital appreciation,
once in rent, but
remember more importantly,
invest in yourself.
Figure this stuff out,
immerse yourself in property,
immerse yourself in education.
God bless, I'll see you next time.
(upbeat music)